i am leah chase
chef and co-owner of duke and chase's
restaurant
i'm 94 years old
i've been in this kitchen 71 years
every day i come in this kitchen 7 30 in
the morning i hit this floor and i don't
leave until we close
but guests come to this city
they know when they come here they get
to get a good bowl of creole gumbo they
get to get some jambalaya they can get
some good fried chicken
they're going to get what i serve
[Music]
the butter just melts in there and gives
it all kinds of good flavor
[Music]
every day i meet new people and they
come to taste the food i cook
that makes you feel good
this place back in the day was a
landmark we became a meeting place in
the civil rights movement
and so you had always thurgood marshall
ernest wright all those big naacp people
black people knew they could come to
dukey traces and would not be disturbed
by anybody
it was illegal for whites and blacks to
be together but they came here
this was a safe haven for all of us
i fed mr obama he was going to eat the
gumbo
and he gets the hot sauce bottle
oh my god
i said mr obama you don't put hot stocks
my gumbo
now that gets around all the
neighborhoods so they said you told him
good misterkey don't be messing up your
cupboard
i was recognized by james beard with the
lifetime achievement award
to me that was unbelievable
sometimes i said i don't know how i got
here but it gives you energy to keep
going
and my whole thing is to make this
restaurant go
i want to be one of the best restaurants
there is
[Music]
you